hi i'm keiko right from New York  University my film hero a story of  Japanese internment it's a film about my  grandfather's experiences at hormone I  hope you enjoy the film  they told you you only take one duffel  bag  here in a house like this  what do you do  at heart mountain my grandfather was  imprisoned for the next three years he  liked two-thirds of the 120,000 others  imprisoned was a United States citizen  I started this project because I wanted  to gain a better understanding of my  family's history  I knew my grandfather would be reluctant  to talk but I felt his experience needed  to be shared this is a photograph taken  in camp I don't remember him this  photograph taken but this was in 1944  that was about a year before we came  back